Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. Eric from Mass has.
In calling in for the entire pandemic, saying
we're about to blow the lid off of this thing.
And he again says it's about to happen.
We're about to get the truth on the pandemic
and when we do, I'm going to be screwed.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 7: And David and.
The CDC is about to come out with the real
numbers of the pandemic, right?
Going to be putting up for the PCR tests don't
work.
So it's going to be half of that.
Speaker 1: So none of that's true.
The PCR tests work.
There's there's actually more cases than the
number that we are seeing.
COVID numbers are not overblown.
We've debunked this endless times a hundred
Speaker 7: thousand and then half of them
with the flu, so be about 200000.
Which person who never had a pandemic to begin
with?
The PCR tests were wrong.
Speaker 1: And of course, all of this is lies.
But Eric really thinks any day, any day, it's
going to come out like a
Speaker 7: vaccine for nothing.
But what will you do?
You will lie and evade and blame everyone
else.
It's going to be funny.
And then the saying, I can't wait.
Speaker 1: Well, show me the numbers, my friend,
because every one of this guy's predictions
over the last two years have been utterly
wrong.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Joe Biden calls for a change to the filibuster
in a major voting rights speech.
We will talk about it.
Extreme weather in the U.S. is believed to
have cost 688 lives last year.
How do you even calculate something like that?
We will discuss, and the Justice Department
is creating a unit focused on domestic terrorism.
What will they do?
Who is in favor of it?
Who is against it?
You can probably guess the answers to some
of those questions.
Get instant access to the bonus show by signing
up at join Packman dot com.
We are still banned from Facebook monetization.
You can use the coupon code app Facebook.
That's Facebook with two deaths to get a discounted
membership to help us make up that revenue
loss effort.
Facebook is the coupon code, and we will see
you on the bonus check.